55 all right you know they say I beauty  is in the eye of the beholder so maybe  you should behold this camels in a  beauty contest it sounds natural doesn't  it yeah this is in Guitar which is he  knows hosting the World Cup right now so  while they're on the pitch trying to  kick the ball around and score and  whatnot well these camels are competing  for a tournament of their own in a  trophy the camels were paraded in front  of an audience although I can't seem to  find it maybe the audience is just the  desert they were judged in different  categories we're still waiting to see  which camel one we believe it's number  six number six yes that's the one with  the extra  smile yeah animals tend to look alike  they do kind of I heard the the talent  category was who could spit the farthest  oh really yes  spit a lot the camel Olympics I see how  it is what beautiful Bedroom Eyes they  have